what is e the two most common logarithms
used unlocked to the base 10 and log to
the base e why are they the most
commonly used logarithms how do we
really understand them log to the base
10 is kind of intuitive it's easy to
talk in multiples of 10 10 100 1000 and
so on log to the base 10 gives us an
easiest skill to work with log 10 to the
base 10 is 1 log 100 to the base 10 is 2
1000 to the base 10 is 3 and we can see
that the multiples of 10 can be managed
with a scale of natural numbers but log
to the base e is what I'm deeply
interested in it's called the natural
log and it's also written as Ln yes log
to the base e is also written as Ln so
log 20 to the base e can be written as
Ln of 20 the natural log of 20 what does
this e sample at a magical number some
call it an irrational constant some call
it a Euler's number but the harsh truth
is this very few people actually
understand what E is to get to eat we
first need to understand growth let's
say a particular thing doubles every
time period on this timeline this is
today and every unit is one time period
assume you have a dollar with you at the
end of the first time period this dollar
doubles and you have two dollars at the
end of the second period two dollars
doubles to become four dollars and at
the end of the third period we have
eight dollars how do we look at this
growth first we see that the numbers at
the end of the time periods are powers
of two it's in the form 2 to the power X
where X is a non-negative integer 2
raised to 1 2 raised to 2 2 raised to 3
and so on this was one way in which we
looked at double growth another way to
look at it is that there is 100% growth
every time period 1
100% of one gives us two $1 was
increased by 100 percent to get to in
the second time period $2 grew to $4 to
plus 100% of two gives us four and so on
so doubling the value is the same as a
100 percent increase so 2 raise to X can
also be written as 1 plus 100 percent
raise to X it's like you're getting a
100 percent return on your investment
but hold on we are making an assumption
here we are assuming that growth happens
in a discontinuous fashion we are seeing
growth in steps here what about the time
in between two time periods we are
seeing no protein between no growth and
it suddenly doubles again no growth and
suddenly doubles but hey that's not how
nature functions everything or every
kind of growth happens gradually if your
height today is 4 feet you suddenly
won't be 5 feet a year later your height
gradually grows when we started we used
to get around 30 views a day and after a
year we started getting around 4000
views a day
it doesn't mean of you count just jumped
one fine day it gradually increased so
growth in nature is never really
discrete or discontinuous let's see how
it really works we take the example of
$1 growing over one year at a 100
percent growth rate first we look at the
annual growth based on what we saw at
time zero we would have one dollar and
at the end of the year we will have two
dollars this doesn't seem right because
all the interest cannot appear on the
last day to make it slightly better
let's divide the year into two equal
parts six months and six months
splitting that 100% the growth would be
50% in the first year and 50% in the
second it would look like this our
initial dollar earned 50% interest in
the first half to give 50 cents more now
what happens in
the second half $1 50 cents remains as
is the growth is 50% so 50% of $1 will
be 50 cents and this time the 50 Cent's
also earned a 50% interest that will be
25 cents this 1.5 is the sum of a
original dollar and the 50 Cent's we
made here so at the end of the first
year we have a original dollar then we
have the dollar that made our original
dollar made and we also have the 25
cents that these 50 Cent's made a total
of $2 25 cents
this is better than doubling if we want
to understand this using a formula it
would be 1 plus 100% over 2 the whole
squared we had half the growth rate over
two time periods this is also referred
to as semiannual growth let's push
ourselves further what if we had four
equal time periods in a year we have
divided one year into four quarters this
is how it would look looks messy but
it's actually very simple if you've
understood the concept it's 25% growth
every quarter the formula would change
to 1 plus 100% over for the whole raise
to 4 we would approximately get 2.4 for
$1 at the end of the first year I
suggest you pause the video and
understand the quarterly growth diagram
really well the 100% is nothing but one
if two time periods then we have to hear
if four time periods then four here so
the formula for n time periods would be
1 plus 1 over n the whole raise to n
clearly more the number of time periods
higher will be the returns this will
give us the dollar value at the end I
probably know what you're greedy brain
is thinking is it possible to get
unlimited money let's make a table now
number of time periods and the dollar
value in the end if it's just one time
period the dollar value is two if two
time periods then two dollars 20
five cents if four time periods then two
dollars and forty four cents if I divide
the year into twelve equal time periods
my return will be higher than this if I
divided into 365 equal time periods it
will be even higher this tells us that a
dollar at the start of the year will
become these many dollars at the end of
one year if the number of time periods
is 365 so if we increase this number
significantly that is a fee increase the
number of time periods significantly
will this number also increase
significantly
okay here are a few more calculations
the number of time periods here is 1
million
notice that the returns improve yes but
they converge around a value which
approximately equals 2.718 and that is
your beloved e we can get infinite money
after all what could be a lame and
friendly explanation for even it is the
maximum possible result after
continuously compounding a 100 percent
growth of a one time period yes
that's e don't forget we had assumed a
100 percent growth here and that's what
he is it's the maximum we get after a
100 percent continuous compounding
growth over one time period
notice what compounding does the first
result is 100% without compounding $1
would become $2 but after continuous
compounding $1 will become 2.718 dollars
approximately that would be a growth
rate of one hundred and seventy 1.8%
that's like the maximum growth we can
have so E is approximately 2.718 it's an
irrational number which means the digits
after the decimal point
do not repeat and go on forever just one
last question what if the growth rate
and the time period change will still
help us absolutely there's no problem at
all in general the growth of the
continuous compounding is given to us as
e to the power R times T
where R is the rate and T is the number
of time periods so if we have a 200
percent growth for five years then it
would be defined as e to the power 2
times 5 we squared e to include two
hundred percent rules and we raised it
to five as there are five time periods
it'll give us e to the power 10 e is
nothing but the maximum possible result
after continuously compounding a 100
percent growth over one time period
[Music]